one of the biggest things that I I
believe is that you have to you have to
understand to fix any problem you need
to understand what the problem is first
of all you can't find a solution without
knowing the problem is again going back
to medicine is very hard to treat a
patient if you don't know what's going
on and the the wheel of life is just a
useful way to break down the sections of
your life broadly you know I sat about
certain examples but break it down and
then be able to give a score to that
section about how happy you are that
you're in the right place so it could be
like I'm just gonna say like you know uh
physical fitness is just a random one
right and you can give your scoring
something you can be zero to ten
whatever you'd like to use but give
yourself a number or an understanding on
this scale about where you are have
several factors in your life you could
break it down into finances you can put
it into fitness you can put into mental
health you can put into your hobbies you
can put in whatever you like are you
achieving what you want to achieve in
that area or are you where you want to
be and it allows you to have a general
look back and go well actually you know
what my physical fitness is pretty
pretty good but actually I don't feel
that I'm doing the things I enjoy in my
life I'm not achieving or doing my
hobbies at all and so it just really
helps to zoom out and then Zoom back
into the areas that you want to want to
work on and you know I I would say like
with
um like with the track traffic light
system it's just knowing what's normal
for you and knowing where you want to be
and then putting in place those changes
and you know I use the idea of a toolkit
all the time at the end of the day like
my toolkit will be different to yours
like I will have a different routine I
probably get up at varying different
times there's certain things I'll do my
day might be similar to you or different
to you and just understanding how you
are what you use to have your
maintenance stuff yeah what things build
your mental Fitness and what things are
in your emergency toolkit and I know it
sounds silly but have an emergency
toolkit so on a day where everything
goes wrong what you're gonna do what are
you gonna do to look after yourself you
know because often let's be honest the
default is drinking for most people must
be frank I mean the hospital bad day on
the wall what should we do let's go to
the pub or end up drinking the irony of
course is that we use drinking and it
makes most things worse you know people
say oh but alcohol relieves stress
actually a recent study showed that even
drinking free glass of wine a week
raises your Baseline cortisol levels
which is obviously a hormone we
associate with stress and inflammation
in the body so alcohol isn't that great
for stress it's not actually that great
for anything really so learning what
your good coping mechanisms are going to
be on bad days is as important as your
maintenance day today yeah yeah like um
the The Wheel of Life is one of my
favorite things to to do personally but
also to do as part of a group
um we were in Austin Texas last week and
we did a meet-up for like 100 of our
YouTube Academy Institute of students
and at the end of my keynote I was like
all right guys we're going to do a
little exercise bear with me on this one
and we just split life up into 10
different things and I just gave them
the the 10 categories everyone's on
their phone wrote just a number on how
how aligned they're feeling with each
one and people were like whoa
you know that's that's really helpful
it's like I've realized I'm not spending
enough time with my friends and I just
hadn't realized that until I literally
was forced to give it to give it a
number and so I think exercises like
that that you would find in
you know life coaching books and things
like that that might seem a bit uh weird
especially for an uh a somewhat
intelligent audience
um I remember the first time we did we
we did The Wheel of Life it was in our
fifth year of medical school and it was
a session called how to be a successful
doctor where the twist of the session
was that you know our tutor doctor later
craps basically said that for Cambridge
Medical students it's almost a given
that success is becoming you know
getting that like oh intense like
ranking in your FPS or in your sd3
applications or becoming the Regis
professor of physic but actually there
are loads of different ways to be
successful whatever that means to you
and he handed out this Wheel of Life
exercise and like half of the class
absolutely loved it half of the Year
group the other half was like what the
hell is this this is a total waste of
time I can't believe I came and followed
all the people if you follow those two
halves and you see who was most
successful at the end and what in
actually most ways you develop that
you'd measure success the group that
enjoyed it would have been most likely
for successful not because size is
amazing but because they were open to
new ways of thinking and towards
introspection people that are that are
Steph that don't want to think of new
ideas they don't want to think outside
the box or understand they might be
Merit in things they don't understand
are often the ones that perhaps don't
end up where they want to be and I've
seen that in my life I mean it's only
anecdotal I'm not backing I'm not saying
there's that I've got evidence for that
but in my experiences generally those
that are adaptable in life are able to
get the most out of it and it's exactly
the reason that I want schools to focus
a little bit less on academic results
and a bit more on building well-rounded
resilient
um you know
children there are people that are able
to work in teams they're able to adapt
to adversity they're able to overcome
and able to find and are able to look
for the positive and useful thing like
even if you're doing something so if you
put me in a I decided to go along with
friends a random thing like salsa or
whatever and being able to go along
while I'm here for an hour let's get
something out of this let's use as a
confidence building exercise rather than
going to something going this is a waste
of time I don't want to do it you're
going to gain you're not gonna gain
anything if you go with attitude if you
go to the attitude to try and learn
something you might Justin to use um the
reason I think that this stuff is also
important and the reason that actually
understanding where you're at right now
is so important is to use a an old Arrow
very much overused adage you know
knowledge is power it's absolutely true
like often we feel feelings of
discomfort we don't know what what the
reason is like why am I even if you
everyone knows the feeling of being
angry I mean you've munched away on a
class and you're probably a bit hungry
off your therapy
um yeah you know hungriness is something
we all under stand but how often do you
walk around hangry and you don't know
it's because you're hungry and it's
actually a girlfriend you mate goes have
you eaten you seem hangry you go oh my
God I am really angry you thought you
were just not you thought you were
literally annoyed about this random
thing that happened this train that's
late but actually you were hungry so
we're not very good we're good we're
good at feeling discomfort yeah we're
not often very good at knowing where
discomfort comes from so if you're
feeling not at ease in your life then
working out where that comes from is
your primary yeah you know that's the
most important thing where does that
come from is it because I'm lonely do I
lack good connection in my day today am
I hyper connected online the digital
space but not really having a meaningful
connection face to face or am I actually
just sleeping like crap you know a lot
of people feel really rubbish a lot of
the time and a lot of it is for a lot of
people it's because it's just don't
sleep enough they they don't sleep and
um if you sleep badly everything else
goes wrong you know so just just having
a little think about where where does
this feeling come from where does this
discomfort from
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye